the way the government comes after you
is they come for your money but Bitcoin
right now is the only solution there are
seven characteristics of money that make
something the hardest money Bitcoin fits
all of those so I can go through them
there's durability which means it's
physically durable it's not going to
break uniformity which means it's all
the same you can't have like like nfts
aren't don't have uniformity it's all
different fungibility which means that
they they all have to be equal
portability gold isn't very portable
because you know you can't run away with
your gold it's very impossible
divisibility you've got to be able to
make it divisible Bitcoin is and that's
really important because if you want to
buy and sell Goods you're going to need
it to be divisible right like I'm not
going to give you this gold necklace for
some bread that you could give me we're
going to want to like cut it in half
acceptability and so on there's so many
so anyway Bitcoin ticks all of those
boxes and one day you have a reason to
to need your Bitcoin I'm telling you
when they come after white men and
you're going to be first they're going
to put you they're going to burn you at
the Stak